when there's a revolution what city
should we meet up
in uh well if there is a revolution and
I pray there isn't because they never
end well but if there is but it'll be
[__] fun huh for like the first 20
minutes when you actually storm the
basal and free the prisoners or whatever
yeah hang your homemade flag from the
roof of the capital or whatever like you
burn the news networks is the first
thing you'd have to do so that'd be the
fun part of the Revolution think that'd
be that that would be definitely be the
fun part but then it gets then you have
like show trial and famines and you have
like all the downside but whatever I'm
not in church so if that happens I will
be so deep in the woods surrounded by my
dogs and I'll say it Firearms um
probably not going to hear from me look
let's just pretend one of your dogs is
named
Firearms I actually have a dog called
firearm yeah I have AK and 47 whatever
you have dude I got bow I got Arrow I
got whatever you know I got all my
weapons in the woods with me um but yeah
and you can even just text me and just
let me know where you're going to be
but I think about that you know what's
Wild I think about that sometimes but
you're going to be in La no I won't be I
live in Nashville oh you don't live in
LA no I live in a place where if
somebody is being weird you can shoot
them um okay because if you're in La you
just get eaten yeah oh well here's a
move you would do in LA you would get in
a boat and go off the shore that would
be the first move and let the other
having grown up on the Pacific let me
just say it's a little bigger than the
chunk of funky River wherever you you're
from okay it's a super big ocean yeah
also [__] men in Jerry's while we're at
it I want say that but go on they're
Marxist is it called chunky monkey
what's the name of your River uh chauna
Chun but I love that that's the greatest
name ever but the Pacific goes on uh
forever and then you make it to Hawaii
like six days later in your Boston wher
yeah right if you've been lost to Sea
for six days you deserve to show in
Hawaii I think it's easy to miss Hawaii
though in the middle of the Pacific you
could yeah that's a long way to Thailand
you imagine they pick you up they're
like you [__] you would is close to
Hawaii like what the [__] I let my wife
Drive no the Pacific is not a good
Escape Plan at all no because South you
have you know Baja Sonata right right
that's going to be a little chaotic it
always is yeah from Los Angeles to what
the the Arctic Circle I mean that's just
like nothing it's like a last like
there's kind of nowhere to go yeah um
but you you get in the woods deep in
there yeah you got a shot you got a shot
Radley up in there with a couple of pups
100% you go full Boo Radley oh live in
the hollow of a tree yeah that's it I
love that me too man it sounds exciting
but I think people start to think that
way how and that's a sad it's
interesting because that thought it just
comes in my head sometimes I've thought
about asking people I know I thought
about asking Joe Rogan where do we meet
up if [__] gets weird and i' never used
to think that I think Jo's gonna leave
his house right he might not but I think
everybody's got a little bit of a place
you know I think some people are
thinking maybe could be I think you want
to do mountainous so I think you go Salt
Lake or Denver you know bronos suck but
so I don't know if I'd go there Utah at
least doesn't have a team um I don't
know but you start to think about that
you want to get up to sea level you know
you don't want nature beating you so you
don't want to drown out you don't want
to be in [__] Johnstown or something
or whatever that place is Jonestown or
Jonestown or Jonestown both of them both
of them bad bad bad purple Kool-Aid
overflowing Rivers um um you don't want
to go anywhere I think is the truth you
don't want to go anywhere you don't want
to you don't want to travel if things go
go sideways I don't I don't think you
want to be on the road I mean that's a
good point the two times I've been in
places for brief periods where you know
there really was no Authority MH um
would that feel like and where was it
one was at Katrina right after the storm
in New Orleans wow you were down there
on bro I was and the other was in
Baghdad in December of 03 when it kind
of like started to get I felt out of
hand and which one was more hectic you
think oh back dad but I but for the
United States I really no one ever says
this I really feel like Katrina was like
was almost unbelievable how chaotic it
was oh yeah oh for real I mean I yeah I
could bore you but oh I've been at a
game when the saints are [__] losing
the Falcons and it gets [__] hectic
enough there is no one there to call
like period and then people start
behaving in ways that are ridiculous and
I saw I saw that with my own eyes and
dead people and people getting shot like
I saw it not guessing and I was just
like this cannot be America like I
always thought if something bad happened
there would be like you just like call
some special number and like dad comes
and restores Order no no at all the
police were looting I saw it yeah police
were looting during Katrina so so that's
um anyway whatever my point is I don't
think you want to travel too much if you
can help it yeah you know it's better to
be in a place where you're just like
this is my place and I'm defending it
with these Firearms but the SEC until
things calm down you know until like
electricity is restored after the MP
attack or whatever yeah because that's
what's going to happen you there be a
nuclear attack no there's going to be
you know it's pretty easy to take down a
society that's digital oh yeah once you
unplug that and then when
but that's a crazy feeling when you're
like okay cuz your first thought is let
me call somebody nope your phone isn't
going to work no calling no oil through
the pipelines no food delivery God's
going to have the busiest afternoon no
Airlines no one on the roads dams fail
like it all you know if you've if you've
put everything online which cuz the
people who run our country are so stupid
they've actually done
that you are so vulnerable that it's
unbelievable and you're using Chinese
servers and switchers and like at that
point you have no you don't need to drop
a nuke on anybody yeah yeah first of all
if anybody do sh do not nuke you don't
need to you don't need to let us at
least enjoy the mystery of it for a
little while too but people are so that
doesn't mean just no door Dash that
means no anything and people one thing
I've noticed in both the places I've
been no Stacy Dash either huh that [__]
you know no Stacy Dash you can't call
any of your call girls from the
interstate god dude what if they start
showing you're like they will they'll be
seeking Refuge at your place remember me
you tip me for no service seeking Refuge
reignment um that was a tough play on
words that's a good one though thank you
dude um but I think yeah but you
wouldn't be able to use money anywhere
no that's going to become no Val like
it's just it's weird we're having this
conversation but even as me listening to
you talk I am my brain I think is
recording this because it feels like it
could be plausible all you need is a
couple of cops to be like you know what
[__] these people as well I'm not going
to [__] quit def I'm not going to
quit blockading or attacking these
people who I know are really struggling
when I'm going home tonight and being
one of them 100% And by the way my kids
my kids are at home and there's now this
happened in New Orleans during Katrina
is cops and I give them all the benefit
of the doubt you know some of them you
do have some criminal cops down there
but you also have good guys too you know
and the good guys are like I'm sorry I
got a wife and kids at home like I'm not
and people are going nuts the thing that
I noticed was it took like zero time
from when Authority disappeared for
people to get super afraid for the
Predators to come out and start praying
on people and for everything just to
fall apart everything yeah and if you
unplug this country and by the way once
you decide you're going to go to war
with Iran as we've apparently the morons
who run our country have decided that is
I mean a very likely outcome that
they're going to do something like that
really ABS absolutely
everyone's like oh they they could send
an ICBM or whatever no it's why would
they bother to throw a missile at the
United States across the ocean when they
could unplug the country and then you
have real casualties Mass casualties and
mass chaos like true true chaos oh yeah
people are not prepared for this they
haven't thought it through our leaders
have not prepared them for it at all
it's like oh it's on your iPhone we
don't have an iPhone and there's no
electricity and there's no water and
there's no way to get anywhere yeah come
on dude and that could happen that's not
science fiction like that could happen
soon and we're not ready for it and as
you said it's not a cohesive country
people are not like oh I'm going to help
my neighbors you don't know who your
neighbors are they may not speak the
same language well you're certainly not
going to also help your government so
that's going to be the weird thing when
the government's like people do this
it's you it you might if you're a lot of
people like [__] you I don't trust you
totally and people have not seen chaos
they don't know what chaos looks like we
don't like when people imagine War they
imagine you know two lines against each
other lobbing artillery shells or rifle
fire at each other there's a certain
order to that and people can can handle
it you know it's dangerous but I can
handle it it makes sense to me it's
orderly it's geometric chaos is
completely different from that chaos is
like you have no freaking idea what's
happening who's on your side who's not
who's a threat who isn't where things
are going
people are not designed for that people
can't handle chaos and they go crazy and
I've only as I said had a taste of this
a couple of times but enough to learn
chaos is the one thing you have to avoid
because that's when people become
animals and really start behaving in
ways that are inconceivable to civilize
people oh we're going to turn into
middle monkeys real fast or we're gonna
like in minutes yeah oh yeah bro dude I
was at a dve and Busters one time right
I'm not even joking [__] power goes
out dude did you eat anyone bro it was
whacka everyone in that [__] dude
people were beating the there was it was
complete darkness right and people yeah
you're [__] feeling around for
whatever you know birthday cake or
whatever you're you know like you don't
even know what's going on yeah but that
was crazy that's a Dave and Busters I
know you
know